-I got this drone because
I thought when Preeta
and I come into the weddin
on the elephants
that the drone
could be kind of, uh --
As I'm saying the words
"drone" and "elephant"
out loud to another human being,
I'm wondering,
is this, um -- is this a lot
-Wedding's been --
They're already
stressful enough, you know
-Yeah.
-Important part is that Preeta
she can't wait to marry you.
So just take it easy, you know
Enjoy the ride.
You only got one shot at it.
-Like, one chance
to, like, get it right.
-Uh-huh, uh-huh.
So just go ahead
and pull it back.
-Yeah, pull it back
and just sort of let it rip.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Colin Jost
They didn't -- they didn't hav
a clip with Tom or Jerry in it
[ Laughter ]
-I was told that they would be
making me Tom after the fact
-Oh. Wait! You thought --
You thought this was, like
a motion-capture situation
-Yeah, I thought that motion -
You know how you normally
put on, like, a powder-blu
motion-capture sweater?
-Of course.
-That's what I thought that was.
And so I kept --
And I was like, they'll --
Obviously, I'm just sort o
saying a couple words,
but they'll put in, like,
arms going crazy.
[ Laughter ]
I do a flip at the end.
You know,
something that makes it fun.
-Yeah, puts a little
more Tom on it.
-A little more Tom on it.
That was my number --
When I told friends
I was doing "Tom & Jerry,"
they were like,
"Oh, so are you Tom or Jerry?"
And I was like,
"Oh, I'm, um, neither.
I'm just sort of a man."
[ Laughter ]
I'm just, like, a human man.
And they were like, "Oh,
so who's Tom and who's Jerry?"
I was like, "No one.
They just -- They don't talk."
I'm just -- They're like,
"What are you doing in it?
I was like, "Oh, just --
I'm getting married."
And they're like, "So, like,
what you're doing in real life?"
I was like, "Yeah.
They don't let me really
stretch a lot as an actor.
It's exciting.
-You were really entertaining me
talking about --
Again, you and I,
we are desk people.
-Yes.
-Our best work
has been done sitting.
And you were saying
that, like, being in a fil
with actual actors,
trained actors,
actors who have been
in other movies, it really -
the difference
in your skill set was obvious.
-Yes, I had a lot of scene
with Michael Peña,
who is not only very funny
but a great actor.
And we would be in a scene
and there would be,
you know,
like 200 extras around us.
They had obviously been
setting up this whole shot
and the scene and the set
for days, and everyone waiting
And then I would come in,
and I would walk into the set,
completely miss my mark,
not even consider where --
It never even dawned on me
that there was a mark.
Walked way past it
up to Michael Peña,
start talking to him,
have a long, emotional speech.
And he's looking at me like,
"Mm-hmm," just, like, smiling.
And I'm like, "It's weird
that this emotional speech
is kind of making him laugh,
but...
And then after the fact,
he's like,
"You were out of focus
the whole --
You were out of focus
the entire speech."
He goes, "You just blew
way past your mark.
None of the cameras
captured you talking."
And he just enjoyed
letting me do it
so he could just
rub it in my face
about how much worse
an actor I am
on just a very basic
"not being on camera" level.
We normally sit at a desk.
-Yeah.
-We don't have to really worry
if we're off a couple inches
It doesn't really matter.
But when there's cameras
that are, apparently, like -
work based on focus and ligh
and things like that,
and when you're not
in those things, it's bad.
-Um, hey, this is very rare,
but we just got some news.
Andy Samberg has reached out
He wants you to check your phone
right now.
-Oh, my God.
All right, well, let me --
I'm filming on it, so hold on.
[ Laughter ]
I got to, like, you know,
take "do not disturb" off.
[ Laughter ]
This is going to
really backfire.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
I just got some texts.
[ Laughs ]
"Hey, are you on with Seth
right now for your interview
Reminder to turn off alert
on your laptop."
[ Laughter ]
Photo of me.
"This you?
If you don't turn off alerts
it will keep popping up
and interrupting.
Can be very annoying."
More coming in as I say this
"Anyway, hope you
getting these in real time
so it doesn't become annoyin
if someone texts you
while it's happening.
Might be bad TV.
Nielsen ratings
could get screwy.
Also, Frisbee sucks, right?"
-[ Laughter ]
-"The dog."
He specified the dog.
The first punctuation he's use
was after "the dog," period.
"Please respond. Spinning out.
-Spinning out?!
-"Need to know
you hate Frisbee."
[ Laughter ]
"Full disclosure --
on peyote right now.
Don't be mad.
[Bleep] pic?
[ Laughter ]
-Is he asking if you want on
or is he asking you to send one?
[ Laughter ]
-He says, "Get or send."
-Huh.
-Damn it.
-All right.
-He knows --
You know what?
Say what you will about Andy
but he knows the biz.
-He knows the biz.
I mean, the Nielsens part
really talks --
really speaks to how intuitive
-Always obsessed
with the Nielsen numbers.
-Can we get you back?
Can we get your visual back?
Oh, there he is.
-Hi, I'm back.
Andy just texted again,
"Remember to turn
your alerts off.
Would hate for it
to mess up Seth's show."
[ Laughter ]
-Very kind.
-Yeah, he's thoughtful.
Hi.
-Hi, buddy.
You, um --
I want to ask a question
about your acting range.
As you mentioned,
they didn't ask much of yo
in "Tom and Jerry"...
-Thanks.
-...but you did a politica
impression this year.
You got to do Pete Buttigieg
-Yes.
-Now Transportation
Secretary Buttigieg.
And you guys actually live
in the same dorm
at, uh...
Harvard University?
-Yes, that's -- that's right
[ Laughter ]
-Did you know him
at all in college?
-Yes.
We were in the same dorm
for three years.
We had a mutual friend who -
so we kind of met
and saw through him.
We didn't cross paths a lot,
I would say,
because he was more involved
in the college side of things.
[ Laughter ]
He perhaps was a more
studious student at college.
-Yeah.
-And I --
-Like he wouldn't use like -
he probably learned enough words
to not say "studious student."
-Maybe. I don't know.
I don't want to put --
I don't want to put him on -
make him some kind of elite.
Your words.
-[ Laughing ]
No, I'm sure -- let him
run Transportation, yeah.
I took a subway every day --
okay? -- to high school.
What does he know?
-Exactly.
-Probably still more.
[ Laughter ]
He -- He was, um...
He was, uh...
Yeah, he was --
I spent a lot of my time,
as you know,
in the Lampoon organization,
which i would describe
as kind of Heaven's Gate,
but we got out, like,
right before the mass suicide.
-Right.
-All the fun leading up to it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I haven't read much about it,
obviously.
You can ask Pete.
Mayor Pete would probably
know more on this, too.
But I sense that Heaven's Gate
was kind of a party,
fun times, right?
-Yeah, I think
it was a good time.
-But of course, the suicide --
-They all went like Nike
shopping together and stuff.
-Yeah, I read the broad strokes.
-Right.
-And the Lampoon was
a little bit like that,
and I think he was more tapped
into human society at Harvard.
-Gotcha.
-And I think he probably
was a --
probably a better student.
-Yeah, well,
you both turned out great.
Buddy, it is always
a pleasure to see you.
Have a great show this wee
with Nick Jonas.
That's very exciting.
I love you, and I will
hopefully see you soon.
-Love you, too.
It's great to see you.
I'm glad that you have a sho
that we can talk on.
-"Tom and Jerry --"
-Very convenient.
-"Tom and Jerry: The Movie" --
-And tell --
Please thank Mayor --
I don't know -- is he confirme
as Transportation...?
-He is, yeah.
-Hmm.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Well, wish him the best,
I guess, you know?
-All right.
He was on yesterday,
so I feel like it's too late
-All right.
Well, do you have an e-mai
or anything for him?
-"Tom and Jerry: The Movie
premieres in theaters --
-Do they still accept --
Do they still accept --
you know how, like,
for Supreme Court stuff,
you can send in
like an amicus brief?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Like, it's friend of the court?
-Sure.
-Do they do that if, you know,
say someone wanted to send
in something
less than flattering
about a nominee for a,
you know, cabinet appointment,
do they accept things like that?
-I don't really know.
I think the important thing no
is, like,
I've got to get this plug in
for the movie.
-Right.
No, no, go ahead.
-"Tom and Jerry: The Movie
premieres in theaters in -
-Is it railroads?
He would just do railroads
-What, for Transportation?
-Yeah.
-No, it's not just railroads
-What's another one?
-Air...planes?
[ Laughter ]
-You don't sound that sure
You know,
airports are privately owned
-What? Wait --
-Yeah, like LaGuardia.
-LaGuardia the guy?
There's a guy named LaGuardi
who still --
-Well, his stuff --
Yeah, there was a man.
His stuff was privately owned,
like his clothes and stuff
But the airport, LaGuardia
it's privately owned.
-Well, this is great.
I feel like you got
a lot smarter
once this segment was over
[ Laughter ]
-I'm just saying!
It's a no-show job.
What's he got to do?
-What's a no-show job?
-Transportation secretary.
-It seems like you want to fil
an amicus brief about the job,
not about the guy.
-No, I'm just saying,
this guy says he's,
like, you know, great at stuff
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you're like,
"What are you gonna do?"
"Oh, I don't know,
just railroads."
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
I'm not telling people.
-It's crazy.
-You know what, I'm not tellin
anybody how they can see
"Tom and Jerry"...
[ Laughter ]
...where,
or when it's available.
-They'll kill me!
You gotta say it!
[ Laughter ]
-We'll be right back
with Harvey Guillen.
-No!